eran unos caros periódicos, difíciles de obtener
y, por esa razón,
la gente iba a la cafetería para leer allí un ejemplar gratuito y compartido.
Una vez que estaban ahi,
conocían a más gente que leía el mismo periódico,
hablaban, compartían ideas y formaban una comunidad.
De un modo similar,
la televisión por cable solía ser más cara,
así que era posible que no vieran el partido en casa,
sino que fueran a verlo al bar para vitorear junto a otros fanáticos.
Pero a medida que el precio continúa disminuyendo gracias a la tecnología,
esta necesidad compartida que nos hacía juntarnos, desaparece.
Tenemos muchísimas opciones asombrosas para entretenernos,
y es más fácil que nunca consumir esas opciones solos.
Las comunidades sufren las consecuencias de esto.
Por ejemplo,
el número de personas que dice tener al menos dos amigos cercanos
nunca ha sido tan bajo.
Creo que una de las principales causas
es que nuestro entretenimiento nos permite estar separados.
Existe una tendencia que invierte esta atomización de la sociedad:
los videojuegos multijugador actuales.
Los juegos son como una fogata compartida.
Son a la vez interactivos y de conexión.
Estas hogueras pueden tener bellas animaciones, misiones heroicas,
a veces demasiadas cajas de recompensa,
pero los juegos hoy en día son muy diferentes
de aquella actividad solitaria de hace veinte años.
Son profundamente complejos, son más estimulantes intelectualmente
y, sobre todo, son intrínsecamente sociales.
Uno de los géneros recientes más exitosos que ejemplifica este cambio
es el "battle royale".
Cien personas llegan a una isla
y el ganador será el último jugador sobreviviente.
Piénsenlo como si fuera una especie de "American Idol",
pero con mucha más lucha y mucho menos Simon Cowell.
Puede que les suene "Fortnite",
que es un exitoso ejemplo del género battle royale
y que ha sido jugado por más de 250 millones de personas en todo el mundo:
desde niños de su barrio hasta Drake y Ellen DeGeneres.
2,3 mil millones de personas en todo el mundo juegan videojuegos.
Los primeros juegos como "Tetris" y "Mario"
eran acertijos simples o juegos de misiones,
pero con el aumento de las salas de juego, después del Internet,
y ahora los juegos multijugador masivos
que cuentan con enormes comunidades online,
los videojuegos se han convertido en una forma de entretenimiento
que requiere conexión humana para su consumición.
Esto nos lleva al streaming.
¿Por qué la gente se graba jugando videojuegos?
¿Y por qué cientos de millones de personas en todo el mundo
se juntan para verlos?
Quiero que se imaginen por un segundo...
Imaginen que aterrizan en un planeta alienígena
donde hay un enorme rectángulo verde.
Y en este rectángulo verde
alienígenas uniformados están intentando colar una esfera entre dos postes
usando solo los pies.
Está muy igualado, así que la bola va de un lado a otro,
pero hay cientos de millones de personas viéndolos desde casa
y animando y emocionándose e implicándose con ellos.
Yo crecí viendo partidos con mi padre,
así que entiendo por qué el fútbol es entretenido y cautivador.
Pero si no ven partidos,
igual les gusta ver "Bailando con las Estrellas"
o les divierte "Top Chef".
En cualquier caso, el principio es el mismo.
Si hay alguna actividad que de verdad les guste,
probablemente disfrutarán ver cómo otra persona la realiza
de forma hábil y con estilo.
Puede que sea desconcertante para un alienígena,
pero conectar a través de una pasión es una característica humana universal.
Los gamers crecieron con ganas de tener este entretenimiento en directo
y la consumición pasiva no les satisface tanto.
Por eso el streaming en directo se ha popularizado con los videojuegos.
Porque el streaming en directo ofrece una sensación de interactividad.
Cuando se imaginen lo que pasa en Twitch,
no quiero que piensen en un millón de streamings en directo de videojuegos,
sino que lo que quiero que se imaginen es un millón de hogueras.
Algunas son hogueras,
enormes hogueras con cientos y miles de personas alrededor.
Algunas son más pequeñas, reuniones más íntimas
donde todos saben sus nombres.
Intentemos participar de una de esas hogueras ahora mismo.
Hola, Cohh, ¿cómo te va?
Cohh: Ey, ¿cómo te va, Emmett?
ES: Estoy aquí en TED con 1000 de mis amigos cercanos,
y pensamos que podríamos acompañarlos en el stream.
Cohh: ¡Genial! Es genial verlos, chicos.
ES: Cohh, ¿puedes compartir con la audiencia de TED aquí presente
lo que has aprendido de tu comunidad en Twitch?
Cohh: Oh, vaya. ¿Por dónde empiezo?
Hace cuatro o cinco años que empecé a hacer esto
y si hay algo que no deja de impresionarme
es lo increíble que es esto para la comunicación.
Hace 20 años que juego videojuegos, hace más de 10 que lidero grupos de MMO
y este es de los pocos lugares
donde puedes conocer a un montón de gente con intereses similares.
Estuve escuchando lo que decías
y me encanta la analogía de la hoguera; uso una parecida.
Lo veo como un montón de gente en un enorme sofá
y solo una persona tiene el mando.
Así que es como: "¡Ey, pásenme las palomitas!".
Pero con 700 personas...
Pero es genial, de verdad, es...
ES: Cohh, ¿qué está pasando en el chat ahora mismo?
¿Nos lo puedes explicar?
Porque no lo veo bien pero sí veo muchos emoticones.
Cohh: Esta es mi comunidad: la "Cohhilition".
Hago stream todos los días.
De hecho, he completado un reto de 2000 días,
por lo que hemos creado una comunidad bastante impresionante
aquí en el canal.
Ahora hay unas 6200 personas con nosotros.
Lo que ven es un montón de "Hola, TED" y emoticones de risa,
emoticonos amorosos,
"esto es increíble", "Hola, chicos", "Hola".
Básicamente una enorme comunidad de gente, de gamers,
que experimentan un evento juntos.
ES: ¿Podemos hacer una encuesta?
Quiero preguntar algo en el chat.
¿Al chat le gustaría decir algo al mundo,
especialmente a la gente de TED que está aquí conmigo,
sobre qué les aporta jugar a videojuegos
y ser parte de esta comunidad?
Cohh: Oh, vaya.
Ya empiezo a ver un montón de respuestas.
"Me gusta la buena onda".
"Las mejores comunidades están en Twitch".
(Risas)
"Nos ayudan en momentos difíciles".
Ese mensaje lo veo mucho en Twitch,
lo que es algo bueno.
"Una comunidad muy positiva", leo mucho sobre la positividad,
lo que es genial.
ES: Cohh, antes de retomar mi charla --cosa que debería ir pensando en hacer--,
(Risas)
¿hay algo más que quieras compartir conmigo o quieres preguntar algo?
¿Algo que siempre hayas querido decir delante de una audiencia?
Cohh: La verdad que no realmente.
Me encanta lo que estás haciendo.
Creo que el streaming interactivo
es la frontera inexplorada del futuro del entretenimiento
y gracias por hacer lo que estás haciendo.
Cuanta más gente sepa lo que haces, mejor para todo el mundo.
ES: Genial Cohh: Muchas gracias.
ES: Retomo la charla pero luego seguimos conversando.
Cohh: Me parece estupendo.
(Aplausos)
ES: Esta es una nueva manera de interactuar.
Pudimos influenciar lo que ocurría en el stream,
pudimos cocrear la experiencia con él
y tuvimos una experiencia multijugador con el chat y con Cohh.
En Twitch, hemos empezado a llamarlo "entretenimiento multijugador".
Porque pasar de ver un video solo a ver un stream interactivo en directo
es parecido a la diferencia entre pasar de jugar un juego para uno
a jugar un juego multijugador.
Muchas veces, los gamers son la vanguardia en la exploración de nuevas tecnologías.
Por ejemplo, las microcomputadoras se utilizaron primero en videojuegos,
y los primeros dispositivos portátiles de consumo masivo
no fueron los teléfonos celulares, sino las Gameboys para videojuegos.
Por lo tanto, una manera de deducir lo que nos depara el futuro
es fijarse en este divertido e interactivo "sandbox" de videojuegos
y preguntarse: "¿qué están haciendo estos gamers ahora?".
Y puede que eso les dé una pista sobre lo que nos depara el futuro.
Una de las cosas que ya vemos en Twitch
es la introducción del entretenimiento multijugador en los deportes.
Twitch y la NFL se han unido para ofrecer streaming de fútbol en directo,
pero en vez de presentadores en trajes
tenemos como presentadores a usuarios de Twitch
que transmiten en directo desde su canal,
mientras interactúan con su comunidad
haciendo que esto sea una verdadera experiencia multijugador.
En realidad pienso que si miramos al futuro,
tan solo unos cientos de personas consiguen ser locutores deportivos.
Son muy pocas las personas que tienen esa oportunidad.
Pero los deportes están a punto de pasar a ser multijugador,
y eso significa que cualquier persona
tendrá la oportunidad de convertirse en locutor deportivo,
e intentar triunfar.
Creo que eso potenciará un montón de nuevos talentos
para todos nosotros.
Y ya no vamos a preguntar: "¿Han visto el partido?".
En vez de eso preguntaremos:
"¿En el canal de quién han visto el partido?".
Ya lo estamos viendo con programas de cocina, de música.
Incluso podemos ver streamings de soldadura.
Todo esto ocurre alrededor de esa fogata metafórica.
Se encenderán millones de fogatas durante los próximos años.
Y sobre cada tema, será posible encontrar una hoguera
que les permita crear vínculos con gente de todo el mundo.
En la historia de la humanidad,
el entretenimiento ha sido fundamentalmente multijugador.
Cantábamos juntos, cara a cara,
compartíamos noticias en la plaza, cara a cara,
pero en algún momento
esa conversación de a dos se convirtió en la retransmisión de una persona.
Como alguien a quien le importan las comunidades,
me emociona imaginar un mundo
donde el entretenimiento pueda unirnos en vez de aislarnos.
Un mundo donde podamos forjar vínculos con base en intereses compartidos
y crear comunidades reales y fuertes.
Los videojuegos, las transmisiones en vivo,
y las interacciones que animan
son tan solo el primer paso
para volver a nuestro pasado interactivo y rico en vida comunitaria.
Muchas gracias a todos por compartir esta experiencia conmigo
y espero que todos encuentren su mejor hoguera.
(Aplausos)